[Music]  you know there is something about that  tangle of strangers press to the other  four days with nothing in common but  they need to go from one place to  another and never see each other again I  see evil on this train  a passenger has died so they got him  after all  you will assume you're skint no no no no  not oh it wasn't perfectly good health  he had his enemies and it he was another  God murder here God rest his soul  someone was rummaging around my cabin in  the middle of the night no one listened  to me if there was a murder what is  going on and there was another the  murderer is with us and every one of you  is a suspect and who are you my name is  acute Powell and I'm probably the  greatest detective in the world  [Music]  [Applause]  you  you